um should we talk about that and lots of
other things with the government
ministers joining us this morning hi
it's great to see you thanks very much
indeed for joining us Mr O'Brien let's
talk about schools very quickly and our
school buildings are literally
collapsing what are you going to do
about it well we are investing across
the piece in uh both maintenance and
indeed new school uh buildings and also
uh driving kind of reforms by getting
schools to work together in
multi-academy trusts which allow them to
work more efficiently so that we get
more for the taxpayers money so as well
as the physical investment we're trying
to drive up standards by giving those
schools to to work together and
replacing failing schools with better
leadership they can drive up standards
over time it's not going to help if the
buildings are falling down though is it
well of course we are making major
Capital Investments across the schools
of state and we will of course respond
to any particular issues whether there's
any kind of issue about safety very very
quickly just as we have in the past so
absolutely we we will make sure that
every child at school is safe of course
okay
drugs knife crime today
um
apparently home counties knife crime
soars it's soaring and Drug networks are
spreading out from the cities and going
into these home counties you know like
um county lines as we as we hear about
what's the government going to do
to try to sort that out well firstly I'm
not sure that's right actually knife
crimes down about eight percent in the
last year neighborhood crime down about
24 and what we're going to do about it
is today we're announcing another 400
figures let me just that was I was
giving the national figure yeah so in
terms of what we use the level but it
was a decade ago knife crime in the Home
Country so you asked the question what
are we doing about this so one of the
things we're doing about it as well as
uh criminal projects like project Adder
that are about disrupting the county
lines that you just mentioned we're also
today investing an extra 400 million
pounds over the next two years in drug
treatment because we know that getting
people into drug treatment dramatically
Cuts crime cuts reoffending and so we're
going to invest 400 million which takes
up the total level of funding by about
40 will have a record number of people
put into drug treatment because you know
when I before I was a politician I used
to work with people who were Street
Homeless and I saw the both the misery
of their lives of those people who were
cracking cocaine addicts but also how
chaotic they were for society the
disruption they caused the cost of
society of that acquisitive crime we
know that drugs and Drug addictions are
behind about half of all crime and
that's why by bringing up the number of
people into treatment to a record level
by having that huge investment that will
help to stop crime and and the causes of
crime really well what's your view on
the drug problem north of the Border
well in truth the worst place in the
entire the UK for drug addictions for a
long time has been Scotland particularly
Glasgow so this is very much something
that's happened in Nicola sturgeon's own
backyard now
um the policy the policy for this is is
devolved ultimately is on the Scottish
government and I do think that um they
do need to do things uh differently
there and so our approach here and South
of the Border has been to to fight this
on all front so firstly having the 20
000 extra police that we're investing in
will have delivered that Manifesto
commitment to have twenty thousand extra
police by March ahead of schedule in
terms of stopping people being released
from prison so quickly sort of ended
early release at the halfway point so
that people serve longer sentences that
they deserve and we have less people
coming out and causing a crime and then
also to get as I'm saying today are the
causes of crime by investing heavily in
treatment so we don't have people
causing crime because of drugs yeah we
don't need to go into the fact that you
know you cut more than 20 or a thousand
police officers and you're just going
back to you were previously is it Nicola
sturgeon's fault that they have such a
big drug problem in Scotland I think I
would say two things so on the one hand
this does predate Nicola sturgeon it's
not entirely her fault but I do think
that the Scottish government does need
to have a different approach and to look
at what is going on in Scotland they do
have it's not just in the UK that they
have the highest rates it is really the
capital of Europe
um in terms of some of these problems
fault I I always think in politics the
constructive thing is to say is what
should we actually do about it and I can
tell you what we're doing in England
which is a combination of more police at
the end of early release plus
Investments and this is just one of them
in tackling the causes of crime we're
also doing things like they say for
streets fund that that help people to
make their own neighborhoods more secure
and to tackle some of these problems
locally so we are tackling this on all
fronts and I think rather than just us
saying blame it's your fault we say what
we are doing about it here and what we
think they should be doing about it
there as well she certainly managed to
keep labor out of government SNP really
wiping the floor with labor at the last
election she's gone depends who takes
over from her it's another blow to the
Tories though isn't it well to be honest
with you one of the things that kept
Libra of government the last election
was Jeremy corbyn and their own and
their their own and their own policies
though the person who was trying to make
him prime minister is now their leader
so there you go but um no I don't think
it was only a Nicola sturgeon that was
keeping Labor uh from being in there and
her going is something that of course
the Scottish conservatives and the
conservatives have been campaigning for
it's an opportunity for uh for us to do
better in Scotland because I think it is
apparent to people in Scotland now that
the SMP are a bit played out in public
services things are not working if you
look at things like the ferries contract
it's a disaster many of the other things
that they're doing are going wrong and
there's a reason that why nickel is gone
now like on the one hand we've always
worked respectfully with her even though
we disagree with her on the other hand
you know her the real rooting through of
gender self ID has been divisive not
just in Scottish politics generally but
within her own party there's been huge
divisions over this things about the
loans that her problems have been
mounting for a while so it's not
completely surprising that she's chosen
this moment to go and of course we will
work respectfully with whoever emerges
as a successor because they do currently
have a majority in the Scottish
Parliament we of course profoundly
disagree with her most importantly of
all about independence so we think that
the people in Scotland made a decision
they made the right decision to stay in
the UK in a national referendum that was
said to be a once in a generation
occasion that should be how it is
because if you just constantly
campaigning for yet another referendum
that is hugely destabilizing for
Scotland it's bad for jobs and for
investment in Scotland yeah
um I'm sure you have loving caring women
in your life um what do you make of the
stuff that we're seeing on the front of
the papers today where the police are
giving far too much information about
Nikki Nicola bully and the fact that you
know she's struggling with the menopause
and so she was abusing our alcohol I
mean is that really what we need to read
about it so uh it's not for me to second
guess a live police operation or to say
what they they should be doing or to
condemn the way that they are going
about their operation and I'm sure that
some other people involved in this would
have a different point of view and say
oh we should have because I heard one of
the relatives saying well we should have
known about this uh earlier on we could
have searched uh differently in terms of
what we can do for people in this
situation that I can talk about and we
are we do have our Women's Health
strategy we are investing in making
things like HRT much cheaper we're
bringing in a prepayment certificate for
that to cut the cost of HRT and things
like that so in the bits that we are
responsible for in terms of women's
health we are a human level it's not for
me you wouldn't want that sort of stuff
about your loved ones being on the front
page of the papers yeah the other the
other thing I probably wouldn't want is
some minister in the government who is
not close to the investigation started
opinion on who should be doing their
jobs how in different ways I mean I mean
respectively it's just it'd be wrong for
me to stick my or in about how the
police are doing the job on this or uh
you know who should have known what and
when I think at the moment there is life
search in a really potential you know a
really difficult situation there at the
moment and uh okay I hope I know it was
one of my loved ones I want to want all
that stuff on the front page that's
that's perfectly a reasonable point of
view but it's not for me to start saying
that the police are doing the wrong
thing by talking about the situation
um I I can only hope for the best
resolution in this and we can talk about
the things that we can do as a
government but at the moment there is
this search going on still and I don't
think it'd be right for me to start to
um first time you've been here in the
studio with me it's great to see you
it's a real pleasure and I really thank
you for having me thank you very much we
look forward to seeing you again very
soon thanks a lot Minister thank you